[Applaudissements]
ils étaient nombreux pour les accueillir
ces marcheurs sont partis à pied de
ripon en outaouais le 6 septembre 40
jours et quelques paires de chaussures
plus tard ils sont à québec et leur
message est clair l'objectif de tout ça
c'est la protection des aires protégées
au sud du québec en terres publiques
d'une centaine d'art protéger qu'on
demande les boisés urbains et
périurbains qui fondent comme neige au
soleil dans un printemps trop hâtif on
demande un observatoire des forêts
indépendant au fil des semaines leur
cause à radier des gens de tous les
horizons comme cet homme de 80 ans qui a
aussi fait la marge de plus de 500
kilomètres le sujet est très bon
pour la terre
notre mère nourricière ou cette femme
venue de victoriaville pour la cause
surtout cela on a beaucoup de talent
mais ben je pense qu'ils empiètent sur
le territoire forestier aussi agricole
on a une grande demande donc c'est
important de protéger ce territoire
plusieurs membres de nations autochtones
se sont également joints au mouvement
citoyen des logements de la faune nous
si c'est bien grave comme que je
m'envoie à mon territoire besoin je me
sens comme un plus sans abri et c'est un
grand plaisir d'être ici à la fin comme
j'ai marché 10 km avec eux au début
parce que les armes c'est le poumon de
la taille ma main et on doit prendre
soin de la terre des mouvements avait
d'ailleurs lieu à plusieurs endroits du
québec pour soutenir la cause des
marcheurs comme à sherbrooke en cinq ans
fuit en ce moment entre la volonté des
communautés des citoyens minutes à
l'environnement de protéger certains
territoires et la volonté du ministère
de la forêt de les garder disponibles
pour l'exploitation forestière donc
vraiment un clivage disputer une
rencontre entre le ministre de
l'environnement du québec et des
militants aura lieu mardi ces derniers
rappelons le de monde qu'on protège
davantage de forêt au sud du 49e
parallèle ici comme un conte et paulette
radio canada québec